foreign
she explained that from the beginning
she felt like she had to hide who she
was or I would leave her and not let her
quote unquote you don't know the real me
it's almost always a contextual excuse
for I am starting to not like the way I
feel in the life that I'm co-creating I
want now
[Music]
this is John with the Dr John deloney's
show
some say it's the greatest mental health
in marriage and parenting show ever
um it's not it is for sure not but I'm
glad that you're here on the show we
talked to real people going through real
challenges in real time and whether it's
it's your emotional health trying to
find peace and joy and sleep whether
it's your physical health what's going
on with your with your mental health
Diagnostics or you're just trying to be
a better husband a better wife
um a better parent
um we have got you covered if you want
to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a s k and don't forget my favorite
supplements on the planet the ones my
family takes the ones I take for years
and years thorn.com you slash delonium
t-h-o-r-n-e.com slash you the letter
diloni and don't forget pre-sale the
book it's here it is here it's not here
it's up there but building an
non-anxious life my brand new book comes
out in October it is in pre-sale now
please pick it up it's got a ton of
um pre-sale things that go with it so
you're it's like if you buy now you get
all this stuff in a pony and I'm not
gonna give you a pony but you get it
it's a lot of stuff
but this is finally a path out of living
a burned out chronically stressed
anxiety-ridden life
and I'm tired of
all of the industries going to war
against our bodies telling us that when
our bodies react a certain way that our
bodies are broken or somehow
dysfunctional they're not they're
working what's dysfunctional is the way
we are choosing to do life and so um I'm
excited about this mom works out about
this and I have been about anything here
uh and that says a lot because I I'm
pretty excited all the time go check it
out go to John deloney.com and pre-order
building a non-anxious life I'm super
hyped all right let's go out to the 806
to Amarillo by Morning and talk to Jack
what's up Jack
hey Dr John how you doing I'm I'm doing
better than I deserve well dude we are
partying man I'm doing about what I
deserve I'm just kidding I'm doing great
doing great what's up
I'm well I'll I'll just uh go right into
my question but uh basically to give you
a summary
um yesterday I thought that my marriage
was over and uh that my wife was gonna
be leaving me
um I'll go ahead and read my question
that I sent over to you guys
um my wife has decided that she is done
with our marriage and wants a divorce I
have I have asked if she wants to try
couples counseling to try and save our
marriage and she said no
she explained that from the beginning
she felt like she had to hide who she
was from me or I would leave her and not
love her after seven years of hiding she
tried she is tired of pretending and
wants to be free to be herself
I never knew she felt this way or that
she was hiding her true feelings from me
what do I do now
and um there's a couple of updates on
that but uh I'll I'll leave it there and
you can yeah give me the updates down
there
um so I uh of course that was before you
give me the updates I don't buy that
letter
okay um and I'll tell you what I mean I
I don't buy her her
um
yeah I don't buy it but keep going
okay absolutely
um so the updates that was that was
Monday night and so yesterday I I
thought we were done uh yesterday
evening I talked to her again
um and she
she does want to try counseling and um I
I think what has happened what she what
I think she was communicating to me is
that
she was trying to hide who she really
was because she was afraid
I wouldn't
love her and then she was trying to
leave because she was afraid I would
leave her when I found out who she
really was does that make sense
absolutely and sometimes sometimes
there's a lot of what I would call
fantasy talk there's a lot like she's
probably been having that imaginary
conversation in her mind for a long time
right and there's something about saying
it out loud
when you hear it come out of your mouth
you realized on its face it doesn't make
any sense
I'm so scared you're gonna leave me so
I'm Gonna Leave You that doesn't make
any sense but inside your body it does
right because your body's telling you to
run run run run and
um because he's about to reject you
don't let him do it you get out of here
first right so yeah that makes total
sense
um the thing that I balk at
um is the quote unquote you don't know
the real me you don't know the real me
and I can't be me
I don't have any use for that unless
somebody has sat down and said hey I
haven't been honest with you
here is what I'm into here's what I
think is funny here's what I need from
you and then you as husband get to say
I'm out on that
now we can talk about I'm having to hide
but people who just bail because you
don't know the real me I I just don't
buy that that's almost always a
contextual excuse for
I am starting to not like the way I feel
in the life that I'm co-creating I want
out
that makes sense okay that does make
sense and she did share some of the
things that she felt like she was hiding
okay
um and I I have her blessing to share
those with you if that's all right yeah
go for it okay
um so the
kind of the antithesis of this is
i i two weeks ago I caught her crying
um and she explained that she was
feeling unfulfilled in our marriage and
the life that we've built together
um we have we have the life of you know
we have a house we we both have
full-time careers we have a daughter
um and she was feeling unfulfilled in
that marriage in that life
um and she felt like she had built our
relationship on a lie
um because when we met
um
I I had never she was my
when we met I was a virgin okay and she
told me the same thing that she was as
well okay
so what she was hiding from me was that
she had actually had a few
um casual romantic Partners in the past
okay
so this is that has nothing to do with
virginity this has to do with
she knows that she married a guy with a
particular value and she lied
right and she's never been able to walk
on firm foundation not because of the
actual action itself but because she
knew she didn't tell you the truth and
that has haunted her for whatever reason
it's haunted her her entire marriage
right
so her saying that out loud did you run
for the hills and say get out
no absolutely not was she did she have
some sort of cathartic did she feel
better after she said it
um
if I had to analyze the situation I
would it looked as though she had let go
of a burden that she was holding on to
for a long time I imagine yeah
uh she didn't exactly say anything that
she you know felt better or that she
she didn't really say anything she just
she did feel
lighter if that makes sense
absolutely man um
it's not a coincidence that she came
back a couple days later
and
said hey I want to try to work this out
I don't think
because my pushback my answer to someone
who all who says I don't like the life
I've built with so and so
I don't like the life we've built
together
I a hundred percent I've been there
myself in my marriage multiple times
the catch is you can build something
else
absolutely right you can build something
completely different is it going to be
awkward yes is it going to be weird for
sure are you gonna have to get new
friends and like the old Seinfeld you
have to get lava lamps and you're gonna
have to well I don't know what your
thing is but you can build anything new
you just got to put the work in you
gotta go get the professional help you
need to learn new skills to go do what
you got to do with this idea that is
just run its course or the idea that I
don't like what we've built cool been
there build something else
absolutely and the Imp the impulse is
just a bail and run and what she did I'm
actually proud of her
that would have haunted her forever she
wouldn't have gotten the relief that she
thought she was going to get by being
out of this relationship with you and if
I'm you brother there's probably more
coming
oh yes I've I've been preparing myself
and I've also been trying to share
things with her that uh I haven't been
completely honest about and I can share
those with you if if we would like to
get into that bring it on man yeah
absolutely
um uh and and you you had asked if I ran
for the hills I I did tell her that I
want to build a new life together it's
awesome good for you that is that is
almost Verbatim what I told her because
I still love her and I love the the new
her that I'm meeting I love her more
than I ever have I I know that's maybe
that's not relevant but no it for sure
is because she took her she took a
chance she took a risk
yeah and her body had told her if you
tell him the truth he's done he's out of
here
and not only were you not out of there
but you leaned in you got closer
I also want to say Jack
when y'all go see a counselor together
it's okay to
be sad that she lied to you for all
these years that's okay
yeah it's all right it's a there's a
weird thing like let's say somebody was
uh sexually abused as a kid and they
don't tell their spouse and then year 10
comes along and they tell their spouse
there's this dual compassion like oh my
gosh I can't believe you were hurt like
that
um I love you and then there's also the
what was it about me that I wasn't safe
enough to tell right that's a normal
reaction
and so
um it's it's not a it's not normal to
keep those things inside not talk about
them but it's also all those all those
feelings are normal you're not crazy
okay but right now it feels like the
whole thing there's a relief there
um what did you feel like you needed
needed to contribute
oh um so while while she was sharing her
her past with me
um I explained to her that I had been
hiding something from her as well and
what I was hiding was a porn addiction
yeah
um and she when I when I told her that
she's actually the first person I've
ever told and you are the second person
and
luckily it's just me and you man yeah
right it's just millions of people
nobody listens to this show dude so
you're you're safe with me you're safe
well thank you if I told my wife
and a million people um and a million
people yup can I how long has that been
going on before you were married
uh uh yes I I would say I found access
to that kind of stuff around age 12 if
I'm remembering correctly
um it is not uncommon
uh well I won't go down that road I'm
glad you told her man
and she felt that disconnection you felt
her disconnection and y'all been about
solving it in whatever ways your bodies
could solve it
so she's not here so I can just ask ask
you what are you gonna do man are you
gonna go to uh an essay meeting once a
week are you gonna go to
um meet with your group of guys like
what are you gonna do
um
what I'm gonna do is uh I I've asked her
what practices we would like to put into
place and uh if and I've told her she
can ask me any questions that she wants
to
um she's still she's still thinking
about it and processing it I want you to
come to her with a plan because what you
just did was you put it
kind of halfway on her
I want you to come with a plan is here's
what I'm going to do
anything you need to do to feel safe in
this relationship or to rebuild trust
I'm in
gotcha and vice versa you held a lie
about joint values that we shared for
seven years plus
all the time we dated so almost a decade
um
I may over the next five or ten years
ask you more questions I may want to
learn more about that and that's not me
being gratuitous that is me
um learning about my wife because now a
whole new Portal's been opened
yeah right and that's just part of
learning and getting to know each other
absolutely
so yeah
um did you have like a specific question
I can help you with I think it sounds
like you're on the right track man
that's not go find it go find a good
marriage counselor and y'all lean in and
commit I think the biggest commitment
you make right now is not how we're
gonna solve all these things but our
commitment is I will tell you the truth
no matter what we are a couple that
tells each other the truth we are a
couple that
under penalty of law under penalty of
death we will tell each other what we
need in the moment in the day and in the
month
I'm not going to hide that anymore right
and you Brothers You've got to go get
help for a long long term addiction
yes absolutely
um I I have to say I think
when I sent the question yesterday the
the what do I do now was kind of uh you
know do I respect your wishes do I do I
let her go do I file first
um because I want to I want to respect
her wishes and do
um
do what she needs to be happy but with
this new information I feel like
um
I feel like the answer is just to keep
keep fighting for her fighting I would
I'm not a fan at all of what I call the
bailout file
it's very very common that somebody
comes in and says I'm not happy in this
marriage we've built together I'm not
happy in this I'm not happy in this
you've been doing this you don't do this
I want a divorce
then they just sit there for months
and so if you want to leave me and and
so often
um man guys leave the house women leave
the bed and go sleep in the guest room
bro if you're leaving me you can do that
but this is my house this is my bed
if you want a divorce from me great you
filed a paperwork
I'm not a fan of the I'll I'll do the
dirty work for you
it's kind of like that Michael Scott
like I declare bankruptcy like that's
not how that works right right
um you can't just announce to somebody I
don't like the life we've built together
so I'm out uh you go file so I can tell
everybody that he filed on me
so that I can tell everybody that he did
this and then in five years this can be
kind of a Blind Side Story right am I
doing that
you're welcome to not sleep in my bed or
our bed it breaks my heart but you're
welcome to do that I'm not leaving
okay right so
um and some of that is this
um I've I've watched several people who
I love through messiness in this area
over the last couple years
there's this idea this feeling that when
I file divorce when we get divorced my
life will be exactly as it is now just
not with you in it
and probably some sort of replacement
vehicle for you
I'll still be in this house I'll still
be in this bed I'll still go to the same
Supermarket our kids relationship will
still be like this
um we're gonna have this fantasy
co-parenting relationship and then I can
have the man of my dreams it's going to
make me all feel great and good and
wonderful
and I am of the impression that
um I call them micro doses but not the
psilocybin kind micro doses of
you have to understand if you file for
divorce we got a kid we have a life
you're blowing up everything there is no
Plug and Play here
and so if you want out you can be out if
you say hey we're just going to start
practicing this we're going to do kids
on Tuesday Thursday here and I'll take
them on Monday Wednesday Friday and then
that very next week it's like well hey I
not doing that not doing that
like we're gonna we're gonna I'm gonna
be an adult you're gonna be an adult
you want to destroy everything and burn
this thing to the ground you're like
you're able to do that in modern America
I'm not participating in that I'm not
gonna be a jerk I'm not gonna be rude
I'm not gonna hold things up I'm not
going to be like never I'm not gonna be
a stalker
but I'm asleep in my bed that makes
sense
absolutely and I know I'm gonna get some
pushback on that I don't care
um the other thing is this
um
I would
I would begin to lean in and I know I
say this like a broken record on this
show I would make it a practice every
day of your life to wake up and look
your wife in the eye hold both of her
hands and say how can I love you today
and if she says I don't know I don't I
don't know I don't
just say give me one thing
and begin to lean into it that way
because what you're all gonna have to
rebuild is not some tactics and
strategies you're gonna have to rebuild
the foundation of this building because
the foundation's it fell over right it
fell over she told you this you told her
this y'all been keeping things from each
other
um you both have been in systematic
dishonesty with one another
all right let's rebuild it we're both in
I do love you she loves you we're gonna
rebuild this thing from the floor up and
we're gonna start with connection we're
gonna start with telling the truth we're
gonna start with how can I love you I'm
gonna go first servant servanthood right
we're gonna go that way we're not gonna
go with I get to look at your phone and
I get to ask you all the questions about
your old boyfriends that I would have
asked you like that's not where we're
gonna start we might we might get there
that's where we're gonna start we're
gonna start with connection with love
thanks for the call my brother um dude
call anytime I appreciate your
vulnerability and you being open
um
be a couple that always tells the truth
be a couple that says their needs out
loud we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hallow for free
hello.com deloney
all right let's go out to Minnesota and
talk to
Kaylee what's up Kaylee
hello how are you so good how are you
I'm good can you hear me okay I can't I
can agree
what's up
well my question is is
um kind of just how can I stop comparing
myself to others
um I feel like I've been doing that for
years and now I feel like I'm
specifically comparing myself to my
sister all the time
and also we have uh
kids who are three weeks apart and I
feel like I'm also comparing
person and my son because they're so
close in age like if her son talks more
than my son does right now I'm like oh
my gosh my son is so behind and
so I was just kind of wondering your
thoughts on that and how I can stop
comparing my just my life to other
people
um it sounds simple like just stop doing
it but I don't know it's like my
thoughts just take over and I kind of
feel like I need to be doing more with
my life and things like that so
this often comes from a place
a home environment where somebody had to
do things in order to get love they had
to make perfect grades they had to
perform on a ball field they had to do
things so that
was that you
you know it it really wasn't I will say
that I've heard you would say
um say that on the show before and I
kind of was um always reflecting back to
my childhood and I grew up with just my
mom and my sister for the most part it
was just just us and my sister was like
straight A's never got in trouble like
just the typical stereotypical first
child and I was like the complete
opposite and my mom literally like truly
never once ever compared us never once
made me feel like I need to be doing
more
um but then I think about like my dad
and he just wasn't in the picture much
like at all and um got remarried two
months after divorcing my mom and had
twins and just kind of started a new
life there so I don't know if it maybe
stems from that but two things one
we'd have to spend some time together
but I it would be such a rare situation
with what you described with your mom
okay that would be so rare and I would
tell you this it's not worth Mining and
going down every rabbit hole in your
mind right yeah
I would be willing to bet
whether it's glances whether it is high
fives whether it is I'm just talking to
your sister right now that straight a
straight a sister
got the nod
the second thing is is yeah it very much
could be it's very real possibility that
there's a little girl in there wondering
what was it about me that dad left
right and I'm gonna keep my head on a
swivel and look for every place in the
world where I'm not the best or I'm not
the prettiest or I'm not the tallest I'm
not making the most money we're not the
smartest kid whatever the thing is
because I'm so paranoid about somebody
else that I care about leaving me and
I've gotta I've gotta achieve Perfection
to get there and of course you know it
doesn't exist it's not real
yeah right um I'm kind of getting a
little emotional right now I just sorry
no it's good you're good you're good
and so I just I just have a lot of
feelings like with my dad
kind of leaving and just not really
being a dad have you ever talked to him
about it
I never have no
it might be worth that conversation do
you still have a relationship with him
yeah we do and he's like if I've ever
needed anything
like with money things like that he's
always housed yeah
you needed something way more important
than money and he left
it's real easy to look at tangible
things like clothes in a car and and car
insurance and say he gave me everything
no he didn't man he left
yeah
you're not crazy
he's just like super involved in
my siblings were
and it's just like he never taught me
how to drive or went to a softball game
or went to my prom and
so I think a lot of
like the comparison and things I guess
maybe stems from that I'm probably not
fully healed from that obviously I'm
crying right now but sure I guess I have
a lot of work to do from from that yeah
yeah I
here's the thing about comparison
um
you have to heal that from the inside
out
and there's not going to be an external
thing that comes in and makes you feel
whole enough to not care how your sister
even more so not care how her her her
toddler's doing but to celebrate the
fact that he's really smart
yeah celebrate the fact that he knows 50
words and you're a kid Only Knows six
yeah and I really want to get
so go there with gratitude
okay
you've heard me say a lot on the show
about keeping a gratitude Journal write
five things at night that you that start
with the sentence I am grateful for and
just do that every night but I want you
to start a gratitude Journal where you
are intentionally grateful for the
success in other people's life
okay I'm so grateful that my sister is
so beautiful
yeah
I'm so grateful that my that my nephew
is just crushing it
yeah it's a really good idea I should be
doing that and
I want you to spend some time
talking to my friend Kaylee in a
positive way
because it's not better or worse it's
just different you're gonna have a
different life you've always had a
different life from your sister right
right yeah exactly
she wore
high heels and you wore Converse and she
made Straight A's and you got dates
right I mean it's like y'all had
different lives right yeah yeah and the
thing is we're so different but like
we're so close like we hang out all the
time of course yeah we have a really
good relationship and she's never made
me feel either like I need to be doing
something more so I'm grateful for that
have you ever told her that you feel
like you uh live in a shadow
professional I've never said that I
think you should
okay
I think you should
yeah I think you should tell her I've
spent so much of my life being jealous
of you because you're so beautiful Your
Kids smart this and this and this yeah
and I want you to know I'm still working
with I still wrestle with that haunting
question why dad left us
and I want you to know I love you and
I'm so proud of you as my sister
yeah well that's what you know I'm
struggling
okay that's a good idea and is that if
you didn't have a good relationship with
her I wouldn't say Don't just bomb her
with that right it sounds like y'all are
super close my promise is that she feels
that disconnection she feels that Gap in
your relationship she doesn't know what
it is
yeah
she just thinks it's crazy sister Crazy
Aunt Kaylee
better than me and I don't know I just
I don't know it's really tough and I
just feel like I need to be like
changing my thoughts around it it is
it's a hundred percent
and what I'm about to tell you to do is
so cheesy and it's so absurd sounding
and it's been magical in my life in
another's lives
but there's something about looking in
the mirror and balling your fist up your
hand up in a fist and put it in the
middle of your chest and looking in the
mirror and saying I love this girl
okay I love this guy
yeah
and then writing down I'm a good teacher
I'm a good mom
I'm a good fill in the blank and I'm
going to make that a repetitive thing
until those thoughts become part of my
life
okay okay
also you can't just think your way there
what does that mean I've had to come
face to face sometimes when I'm
struggling with comparison that that
person actually does work harder than me
they are smarter than me and some
sometimes I've had to up my game
yeah right sometimes my comparison has
been has been right
okay yeah yeah I can see that too but
also like uh my my buddy Lane Norton
he's ripped beyond measure and he lifts
like a like a forklift he can pick up
that much weight like a house
and when I'm around him
dude talk about comparison
he's handsome he's really successful in
business he's a world champion I am not
those things I'm a YouTuber Kaylee you
know what I mean and I joke you're a
good YouTuber I go jogging right but
here's the thing I don't want that life
he has
like that's not I I I love cheering from
my friend
I don't I don't my my buddy who's an
attorney I love that he's so successful
I don't want the life of being a lawyer
yeah right so it's it's in celebration
it's in recognizing I feel myself
comparing and being like yeah he's a
world champion lifter right I'm not that
um or when I was a teacher like this
person's an incredible teacher and they
work at it too a lot I don't so I cannot
be a teacher I don't want this life or I
can work really hard at getting better
at it but all that comes back to that
comparison which is
I'm good
and you cannot get that peace
externally has to come from the inside
has to come from the inside out
and so I want you to spend like I said
spend some time in gratitude for the
success of other people I want you to
practice not staring at your own belly
button and looking up and out
and then I want you to take that same
posture and look in the mirror and look
at Kaylee and let her know that you love
that girl you love her
and
here's some things about her that I do
love
and here's some things we're going to
work on
let's practice that for 30 days 60 days
90 days and let's also bring your sister
into the vulnerability
struggle with this do you struggle with
anything from Dad I still struggle being
second to you I still struggle with why
he left do you have anything that haunts
you and she might say no you're crazy
she's probably not gonna say that
practicing
you're a great sister Kaylee your little
one your son is is lucky to have you
your nephew's lucky to have your
sister's lucky to have you
[Music]
Haley's looking to have Kaylee
we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
Boise Idaho and talk to the great Nicole
what's up Nicole
hi I'm so excited to talk with you today
I'm excited to talk to you what's up
okay I just want to say before I start
that you've helped my marriage in so
many ways
like every day my husband gets home from
work and he'll literally ask me what new
thing are we gonna try from that process
to meet man today
it's been you've been amazing so thank
you you're welcome but listen you can't
be like
when you're mad at him you can't be like
well Dr John says that you can't do that
you promise
I promise you do I could tell you don't
I totally have don't weaponize me I
already have enough people don't like me
that's fine all right I'm gonna be
walking through Boise one day and he's
gonna be like hey we got a problem and
I'm not that tough I'm not that tough
all right so how can I help you today
thank you thank you for thank you for
being in our gang and for saying kind
things that really makes that's awesome
um so my question is how do you know
when it's time to find a new job or if
you need to do more trauma work or
change your lifestyle
well I think it depends yeah
you're you're what I'm a kindergarten
teacher
I really do love it I love my kids I
love the act of teaching but I am really
struggling with living in this like
constant state of fight or flight during
the school year
um
therapy let's back out of trauma therapy
what are you scared of what's your body
reacting to in an eighth in a with a
room full of kindergartners
um
I've been physically hit in my classroom
I've been spit on
um and so it's that aggression
is your school one of these increasingly
um
I can't even wrap my head around how
insane this is that and I know it's
five-year-olds like I know sometimes it
does that doesn't matter that doesn't
matter that doesn't matter
um
what matters is you have an
Administration that will remove those
kids from from the learning environment
correct will they
no
or they will for a moment and then
they're back
after they calm down and have a laffy
taffy or whatever it is with no
intervention
correct yeah here's what's here's what's
happening all across the country and
it's going to keep happening because of
the coward
cowardly
an insane way
School administrators and school boards
are are setting up teachers to be abused
screamed at yelled at spit on hit at all
levels
because they will not remove troubling
kids from the learning environment and
they are destroying the learning
environment for every other kid in that
room
and so I'm gonna tell you you're not
safe in there
and let's be super clear if those kids
are doing it they're coming from homes
where that that kind of is either
tolerated or that kind of behavior is
picked up
right yeah
it's learned somehow so I'm telling you
if you're my wife
who my wife was a teacher forever and
that's that's her world and she said I'm
tired of getting spit on and hit by kids
I would say quit today
and I need you to hear I need everybody
listening I need you to hear me say I
dedicated my life to Educators both my
phds come out of a College of Education
that's what I love that's who I am
um I love spending time with
administrators I love spending time with
schools I love spending time with
teachers that's my world I married one
for God's sake I love that crew and
I'm not going to subject a group of
people
to insane violence to insane all-day
everyday disrespect a disrupted learning
environment
um
because people are too cowardly to take
on obnoxious annoying parents I'm not I
just can't I can't good conscience say
well you just gotta tough it out honey
yeah you know what I mean now if you're
wired for it
some people are
like Bring It On
if you're wired for it what you have to
do is to work outside of the classroom
so you can be well so you can go back in
right right exactly they're having a
hard time with because I mean I love the
kids so much and I'm good at what I do
it's taking me a long time to be able to
say that out loud but I'm good at it
good good the kids deserve that but it's
hard because I
my body I shut down whenever those
things happen
I would be willing to bet you money you
shut down
bigger you shut down before that
what's what's a bigger shutdown
I don't know
because um the great there's there's an
extraordinary book I recommend everybody
read it it's called burnout by
um Emily nigotsky and her sister I think
it's Amelia nagotsky
um it's it's excellent and it's written
to professional women but I think men I
got a lot out of it and I've recommended
it to men all over the place too
um but they distilled burnout down into
three areas
the feeling that number one nothing I do
matters
I can come at six a.m and tutor I can
come at six a.m and help these kids
learn how to count I can come at 6am and
clean up the room I can stay till 7 PM
nothing I do is going to change these
kids lives nothing's going to change the
system nothing's going to change
anything
second one is this deep and profound not
tired it's exhaustion
it's in your bones right it's this
overwhelmed when I pull into the
driveway I of so School building my body
starts to shut down because it can't
handle what's coming
and then the third one is
I think the most damning one is is this
increased isolation it really starts to
siphon off other people from you and
it's isolated isolated isolated isolated
yeah I could see that because I get home
and I just I don't want my husband to
touch me I don't want to talk to him I
just want to go to bed which then your
body starts yelling I need connection I
need connection I need connection
yeah and then it runs out the door and
starts this whole process over again you
see I just that spiral spins Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter
yeah I see that so when I'm talking to
First Responders when I'm talking to
people who like
or emergency electricians they got to be
up at 2 A.M hanging from Up a poll
fixing electricity so a whole
neighborhood block can can have Heating
and Cooling right
um what I tell them is you have to have
to have friends not in your industry
that you hang out with on a regular
basis
you have to have regular intimate
contact with your husband or your wife
just put on a calendar
you have to be safe in your work
you have to deal with the fatigue and
often we think dealing with fatigue
means doing nothing it's usually the
opposite I have to start an exercise
program
I got to start honoring my body with
what I eat
I've got to start and you you think
right now like I couldn't possibly move
and go to the gym after the day I would
tell you that would transform your life
um my buddy Sal de Stefano with the Mind
pump guys he's told me that when he was
a personal trainer people used to
um sign up for personal training with
him
and they would skip because they didn't
have enough they would say I don't have
the energy today
and he would say you're paying for it
and they would come and they would come
and they would come and he said within
six months to a year
they would cycle off right so they would
see it have a trainer and then not have
a trainer then have a trainer then not
have a trainer he said he'd get a call
from these clients and they would say
hey
I'm out of energy I gotta start working
out again
because they realized that energy begets
energy that the path towards a body
feeling like it can handle more is
movement exercise you might be a
crossfitter I don't know you might be
running marathons I don't know
definitely not I just know because my
community has been teachers my whole
career that when you go to work at 7 A.M
and you deal with 30 people running
around everywhere and an administrator
that's running around everywhere and
um no support and angry emails from
parents that your school district expect
you to respond to every 14 minutes and
by the way get off the computer but why
aren't you responding to seeing all
those things did they get home and then
they collapse
and then they grab something to prop
them up unhealthy they grab another
drink they just Netflix themselves out
and that starts a cycle of
right and then your body just says hey
I'm out yeah I don't want this life
I think the biggest thing is I've
noticed I'm just so much happier since
we've been on summer vacation
I just feel light and happy and yeah and
so my question to you would be
can you recruit like what are you doing
to feel light and happy
because you're doing different things
it's not just the absence of
what are you doing
and it can you put that into practice
for your school year can you be
responsible for some new boundaries
meaning I leave at four
ta-da oh I need you to do all this work
unless well I I leave it for
then we're just gonna have to yep you
you might have to but I don't do 12-hour
days
yeah right I do not I do not have kids
that spit on me they're not welcome in
my class
and that's something I guess I have a
hard time like I'm I'm allowed to say
that like I think I think at some point
teachers have to start saying that or
the entire education system in the
United States is going to implode on
itself
yeah
and I know that's a huge burden for you
and you don't have to carry it and if
you're not going to carry it I applaud
you but you got it you gotta get out of
that job because you're not safe
part two is like
I'm thinks we're trying to get pregnant
and so I'm worried about even if I do
get pregnant the stress on
tomorrow's worries be thought through
tomorrow
yeah that's a tomorrow thing
what I would like to see you do is build
a life worth living
and let your job be a part of that not
try to survive the life you've created
because of the job you have
and so I'm going to send you a copy of a
brand new book it's called building a
non-anxious life okay
okay and it's got six choices that you
and your husband can make together
on building a non-anxious and non-burned
out a non-chronically stressed life
and as a part of that we all have to
work I would be willing to say work is
important we're not designed to just sit
home and collect checks that's why their
whole country went crazy
when the government said 300 million of
y'all are not essential we'll just send
checks you all stay home we went crazy
we're not designed to not have a purpose
and a role and so
work hard work is a part of that
dangerous Adventures are a part of a
non-anxious life but they have to be in
the right context and you have to have
connection and community and safety and
health and healing and all these other
things
so that you have Bedrock to Anchor into
and you can repel off and do the hard
job
that makes sense you see like it inverts
everything that we're told about how to
do I just quit this job maybe
Maybe
but I hear in you you love it
I really do I love it and you're really
good at it
and you see these kids and you are the
first other adult many of these kids
have ever interacted with besides their
parents or their grandma or whoever and
you're real real good at it
just getting exhausting
so maybe before you quit you sit down
and you back all the way out you say
okay how can we build a life
so that I can both go do my job well
and when we get pregnant
and have a bunch of little Knuckleheads
running around that I can be a great
connected mom there too
and if I choose to stay at home and we
have kids great we're gonna cross that
bridge when we get there that's not
today
it's not today
and let this be like for every
administrator every principal every
teacher every school board member
you have to make the learning
environment a safe place and I don't
mean safe in the Wawa I can't hear
things I'm uncomfortable with that's not
what I'm talking about at all I think
that's insane and nonsensical too
what I'm saying is if a teacher's
getting hit or spit on or cussed at you
have to remove the kid from The Learning
environment period
and I'll go this far
I don't care if that kid has trauma or
has reasons for acting out as a child I
fully understand that I've dedicated my
life to sitting with those kids but they
can't be in this environment because
they don't have the tools to be there
they need some support and help and
burning the rest of the learning
environment to the ground and running
every teacher in the country out of
their job cannot be a part of the
solution
it can't be
God is something different guys God is
something different
great teachers like Nicole are heading
out the door and we cannot have that I
got two little kids in public school I
got a vested interest in this please
let's solve these challenges we'll be
right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we're back I'm so grateful
that y'all joined us today don't forget
go to John deloney.com and pre-order my
brand new book building a non-anxious
life it's going to change your life it's
going to change the life of your family
your kids of your community
um thank you for being with us thank you
for being in our gang and thank you for
picking up this book
um today's uh song of the day is shout
out to our first caller they're from
Amarillo Texas It's the Great and
Wonderful Depeche Mode
they're actually one of my favorites
yeah the first call is from Amarillo
right
yes the first caller made it sound you
made it sound like Depeche Mode was from
Amarillo they are for sure not from
Amarillo not at all nope no they would
not have been accepted in Amarillo Texas
Depeche Mode in their song Policy of
Truth
you had something to hide
should have hidden it shouldn't you
now you're not satisfied with what
you're being put through it's just time
to pay the price for not listening to
advice and deciding in your youth on the
policy of Truth Listen husbands and
wives
tell the truth
even when it's hard
we'll see you soon love y'all
[Music]
foreign